all right hello everyone
welcome to my grandmaster's choice
i'm grandmaster steven zerk and today
i'm going to be covering a couple
pretty famous opposite side castling
attacks this first game
is between one of my favorite players
grandmaster ali under alexander elijah
and another top player from his era
marshall
frank marshall in this first game
i'm going to see how from a pretty
innocuous middle game position
i just cleverly orchestrates opposite
side castling
in a position where it's far more
suitable to him because his attack
arrives much more quickly and then
again orchestrates this attack perfectly
so we start out with d4 knight f6
c4 d5 now this
this is something especially when i
review games that are in the say 1500 to
1800 rage unleashes
i see this opening a lot but it's not
quite best
and the reason is that when white takes
on d5
black isn't able to recapture with a
pawn which is
usually what black wants to do and
that's why
generally speaking in this position
black wouldn't play knight f6 they'd
if not capture on c4 play e6 or c6 so
they can recapture with a pawn
the difference is in this move order
when white takes on d5
marshall when elijah takes on d5
marshall is forced to recapture with the
knight
and this means that white gets some
extra central control right black has no
pawns in the center and white's traded
the c
pawn for a deep on both of which are
good news for whites
and ayeking goes for the immediate e4
another move that's good here
to avoid some tactical tricks is
actually knight f3 i believe this is
what this is what john bartholomew
recommends actually
and e4 is to come shortly followed by
knight c3
with again a very good position for
white white just gets the more
comfortable center for free
and that's why this move order well it's
not going to lose you the game
it's just not best right it's not
fighting for the center enough
if black tries something to stop to stop
e4 why aside from causing problems with
queen b3
white can play knight c3 or even knight
bd2 really insisting on getting this e4
move in
and then goes for the immediate e4 which
is also good for white
and after knight f6 the reason this move
order is a little
riskier maybe a little more double-edged
is that if white goes knight c3
black has this move e5
which does stake some claim in the
center the idea is if white takes
black can take on d1 and either
recapture
right knight takes knight takes e4 or if
king takes knight g4
in this line either recapture gives
black some good play
so here white maybe just plays d5 or
knight f3 again with a good game
but ayaken didn't want to allow this so
he played a bit of an unusual move here
play bishop d3 the idea is to guard the
pawn
and now after e5 he can take on e5
without having to worry about this queen
trade and the subsequent counter play
and of course if black takes on d4
classic trick everyone should know
bishop b5 check and it's goodbye to
black's queen
all the same marshall responds correctly
by playing e5 anyway
and after takes knight g4
right's position's a little open this
bishop is a little awkward and that's
kind of the price of developing this way
it would rather be on c4
and black will get this e5 pawn back so
after knight f3 knight c6
i can end up trading these bishops and
just says okay you can have the pawn
back
and so we get to this position even
though marshall's recovered the pawn
even though this center is not as
monstrous as one with two pawns would be
white still has an extra center pawn
which gives him more influence
and he has this majority on the king
side that has the potential to be very
powerful
especially an unopposed center pawn that
can advance can really cramp black for
example on e5
and here marshall makes a bit of a slip
so marshall takes on e5 with the queen
all right this is the more active move
right for example it makes castling
extremely inadvisable
and it does mean he has a lot of control
over the center of the board
the problem is when white starts with h3
this knight is kicked back it turns out
that when these pawns move forward
without any pawns to restrain them on
black side
they're going to gain some very useful
tempi targeting these pieces
so because of that say it was a little
better to take with the knight
right this trade black would be pretty
happy to make and now there's only one
piece in the center this knight can head
to good squares
it might go to c6 and d4 at some point
if not if it's not traded
and all in all just a little more
precise but after queen takes
it goes h3 and after knight f6
and now the question is how to play this
position
so here again white has a strong center
but one thing you'll notice is that
white's dark squares are kind of weak
right this black queen
is doing a great job controlling these
pawns
and these central squares and all of
these pieces that white has in the
center
they're all actually focused on
controlling the light squares
white would be really happy if for
example he could play knight f3 here
right this would take control of these
squares it would kick the queen out
and support this pawn but seeing as
there's no way to do that
he finds a very clever maneuver here to
instead enable
enable his pawn advance and actually
serve another purpose which i'll get to
in a second
castling an f4 is not a bad idea
it does mean that black black gets some
play in the default because
it leaves these squares a little weak
too black can play queen d4 here for
instance and get some good active play
that said this is also a logical
maneuver but we're going to see why what
i just did was even better
because he plays queen d2 and after
bishop d7
he plays this very nice move queen e3
and the re so this is very good for a
couple reasons first of all it doesn't
just support f4
it it stakes a good control over the
center in general
right it's balanced well with all of
white's light square control
but it also it targets a7
and the reason this is good is it makes
it difficult for black to castle
queenside right if black castle's here
white simply grabs a pawn
so this in a way this makes it more
difficult for black to castle here
and actually in the game it induces
marshall the castle kingside
right into this spawn storm and this
actually proves to be what decides the
game
so best here is pro les here is
insisting on castling queenside perhaps
with queen a5
right and then followed by queenside
castling and this way
black can fight for the defile and
white's pawn storm
it takes a lot of space but at least it
doesn't create any immediate direct
threats
instead after bishop c6 white castle's
queen side
and here this is where black i'd say
really needs to appreciate the danger
strategically
now already if black plays queen a5
white for instance has bishop c4
and castling queen side is already
problematic
knight d7 white can throw in knight t5
and if black castles white can shatter
the bond structure
so generally speaking black's lost some
time and white can make it difficult for
him to do what he should do
that being said castling kingside
is a very serious strategic error and
this is why
this is actually one of the big things
that differentiated marshall
who was a great player but had
terrible scores against three world
champions last year kappa blanca and
alakan
right even though he was one of the best
tacticians of the day
he really struggled against them had
very negative scores
and the reason is that they were much
better at getting the positions that
would reward their tactics than he was
this is an example this whole maneuver
by white this queen to e3 and queenside
castle
has put black in a very dangerous
position which
might not be immediate obvious be
immediately obvious
but was judged well by alien
so white starts with f4
queen back and e5
but again you're already seeing the
first tempo gained at the moment this is
pinned but in the near future right it's
going to target this knight and force
another move from black
and you can already kind of see the
attack in the works
you can see how even though the king's
not in trouble yet
it will be in the very near future
and meanwhile right black would in
return with the opposite side castling
black would like to attack on the queen
side
but you can see just how far behind
black is compared to white
white started with a pawn on e4 and with
free tempe to gain on these pieces
if black spawn were on b5 and a5 instead
of back here it would be a different
story
but we're going to see anything black to
do on the queen side is just much too
slow
so black goes rookie 8 right this
targets e5 makes f5 more difficult
so white reinforces with rookie one
again covering this pawn
and after rook d8 white goes f5
queen e7 and now it's probably now it's
a little more obvious that
strategically white is definitely the
one achieving their goals
like black is definitely the one that
has some things to worry about
but okay for the moment it's not over
i can goes queen g5 right just getting
out of this pin
can't take on f6 so getting out of this
pin makes these pawn advances a serious
threat
and here marshall blunders he said it's
it's very tricky to play a position like
this
but the best way for black to play was
actually to move this queen out of the
way
if black goes queen f8
right it's saving a tempo as we'll see
on the game
and if white takes on f6 which looks
very natural right it seems to be
breaking up black's kingside
first of all black tactically recovers
the piece taking on e1
and taking on d3 right these traits have
weakened white's attack
and black's pieces i mean this is not so
easy to judge during the game right this
is very easy to say in hindsight but it
would have been more difficult for
marshall to judge
while the game was going black's pieces
cover enough squares the bishop prevents
any rookie invasions
and the row covers d8 so there's no
taking in queen d8
and furthermore this bishop is actually
very well placed restricting this knight
this knight can't join in the attack
either if it could get to e7 it would be
a very different story
so concretely this play even though
again it looks a little scary allowing
this pawn to f6 as an extra attacker
this was the best way for marshall to
create some chances
instead of that instead of retreating
the queen
he decides to play knight d5
and again pretty natural move right
moving the knight out of danger
to the most active square trying to
create some activity for black
but it has it has a pretty simple major
downside
and that is that now f6 comes much more
quickly
it comes much more quickly it comes
without allowing these trades that would
have been so good for black
and it forces queen f8 anyway
so we have the position with queen f8
already
but white's gaining time and as we're
going to see the attack hits very
strongly
now though now again white's position
with these pawns is obviously very
strong
but if your opponent plays well you know
even if they don't play well even if
they ponder
there comes a point where you have to
start playing more concretely to
actually use your advantage
you have to read out the attack
sometimes you have to allow some counter
play
as long as you've carefully read out
that it's not going to be enough that
it's not going to work
and he goes bishop c4
so this is somewhat committal it allows
this capture on c3
but it creates some very immediate
pressure on black that concretely
just works out well for white
so marshall takes on c3 as is logical
and the point is not to take back this
would be some trades which would help
black
but the point instead was that white
takes on d8
and when black takes back white now
takes on g7
so this is very strong for tactical
reasons
right black can't recapture the pawn
because the rook is hanging
and it gains another tempo on the queen
right we've seen this poor queen be
chased all the way back to f8
and now it's still being chased and
furthermore
with these trades the move e6 now
becomes very strong right the knight is
out of the way this rook is off e8
so e6 is simply going to completely
break up black's king side and leave it
indefensible
so if black just plays queen e8 white
plays e6 we're gonna see this is very
similar to the game
before playing that marshall throws in
this move knight takes a2
so just almost a shot in the dark for
some counter play
pretty classic martial thing to do and
practically speaking a good way to play
this position
because objectively white's attack is
much too strong black can't reasonably
expect
to hold off this attack so going for
some play of his own is
again both theoretically the defense
won't be enough so it's worth creating
some offense
and practically if you go if you go on
the offensive it's much easier for your
opponent to mess up
we're gonna see that well of course he
didn't mess up being a world champion
eliakin had some
had some chances to mess up this game
thanks to this try
if he takes on a2 the point is black can
go queen c5 check
well this position is still winning for
white still
very good black at least can look for
some counter play maybe with bishop e4
and so on so instead of that
place a clever move she plays king b1
all right saying this knight doesn't
matter in the short term
because this attack is completely
winning and this knight on a2
even if i let it live it's not going to
do anything
right if knight c3 check white can take
now
and now black has no checks right now
there's nothing
now there's nothing to worry about here
anything black can do is much too slow
queen a3 queen d8 this just loses
so instead of that marshall leaves the
knight as well for the moment
and plays queen e8
so now again white simply continues e6
right just threatening to win the game
on the spot
and again there's just no wave
defensively for black to hold this
position
black takes on e6 white takes back and
this battery just ends the game
or actually this is even simpler
and black loses everything there's no
good way to defend f7
so marshall does the one thing he can in
this position
goes again for some tricks for some
counter play with bishop e4 check
and once again white has to be a little
bit careful
first of all if white takes the knight
now this would be a real tragedy
just black checkmates
taking the bishop wins
black does get to play rook d1 again
don't walk into mate
but king c2 and after b3
this would beat back the attack
but white plays even more simply aiken
simply says i'm not
my attack is about to win the game
there's nothing you can do about it
i'm not going to allow you any checks at
all and he just goes king a1
he just leaves the knight here and
ironically this knight makes things
easier for white this knight actually
serves the purpose of a white pawn
if this knight weren't here black would
actually have mate with queen a4 check
and rook d1 check
or black would actually win with these
checks
so he says okay your knight's doing me a
favor here i'm just going to leave it
and again it really the material doesn't
matter much because this is completely
crushing
so taking on f7 is an extremely strong
threat
marshall plays f5
the idea that after e7 it goes rook d5
for just the moment holding off the
bishop
creating some defensive play if white
plays a little carelessly and takes on
d5
he can at least block with this although
even here rook d1 is completely winning
even
here rookie one ends the game
but of course aliexin finds a simpler
way simply plays queen f6 now while the
bishop is still here
rookie 4 is winning as well this
structure is just much too flimsy
he plays queen f6
and after queen f7 right queen f8 would
mate so queen f7
and eat queens
and here marshall resigned because queen
takes c8 is forced
white takes on d5 and he mates
and the attack the attack concludes
and again you can see how useful this
knight was
to white not to black
so a very finely executed attack by akin
and more generally i also want to
mention how clever his play was to
induce
to induce a good attacking position in
the first place this is one of his
trademarks and it's what led to him
getting so many vicious attacks
even in calmer queen's gambit decline
type positions even in what seemed like
a fairly normal
opening position because he
he created a position where attacking
was strong and then attacked very very
well
so a great game from him and this game
too is i think a great example of
why aliekin and was this world champion
was this absolute top player one of the
best ever
and marshall as strong as he was as good
a tactician as he was
was not up to the same level it's really
the good strategy behind the attack and
not just the attack
and these pawns were absolute monsters
alright so for the second game it jumped
to another one of the strongest players
ever
this is a game by bobby fischer
against another top player of the era
ben larson
these two actually had a very good
rivalry
in this game fischer opens with his
trademark e4
arson plays the sicilian and we actually
go into what was quite popular at the
time
even at top level we go into a dragon
now fischer actually did not
fisher did not have a ton of respect for
the dragon even in a time when it was
played much more
he mentions that the attack he carries
out this game he carried out in a lot of
skittles games a lot of blitz games
so we go into one of the main lines
bishop b3 bishop g7
f3 alright the idea after bishop b3 is
if black tries to harass the bishop with
a knight g4
it fails tactically to bishop b5 check
this is a good dragon tactic to know
whichever color you play
because now if black tries to block the
check i can simply grab the knight
so for the moment this bishop is safe on
e3
black goes bishop g7 and now white plays
f3
very standard pawn setup in this line
all right securing e4 and preventing
this knight g4 maneuver
and black castles again all of this has
been seen a million times this is the
main line
queen d2 knight c6 yeah dragon's kind of
iffy
this is true although at the time the
dragon was considered to be on much less
shaky ground than it is today
this game was actually one of the
influences
for the dragon's current reputation
and in this position in this position
the most popular move is actually the
castle queen side immediately
this does allow concretely this allows
an immediate d5
and there's an ocean of theory here i'm
not going to dive into but suffice to
say
practically speaking it's very dangerous
for white if they don't know exactly
what they're doing
but objectively black's standing on
somewhat shaky ground
in this game though fischer this is
somebody's trademark plays a much more
straightforward move
which is the other main line which is
this 9 bishop c4
stopping d5 creating attacking potential
on this diagonal
and just preparing to castle queenside
anyway
the downside to this move though is that
black can take
and while black's not getting de-vivin
thanks to this bishop well black's not
getting d5 then
black can offer this trade
and if white takes this pawn structure
might look a little funny
but it's perfectly good for black black
has
a lot of central control this d5 square
white's usually so fond of
is not usable without the light scored
bishop attacking is much more difficult
so because black doesn't mind this pawn
structure white has to retreat the
bishop
you can kind of see the downside right
white's lost some moves black is
countering white's attack on this
diagonal
and all in all this is still a playable
position for black
but as we're going to see it gets into
opposite side castling
after queen a5 fisher castles queen side
again this is all well known
and this is where the standard plans
come into play right king on the queen
side king on the king side
standard plan for black is pushing these
pawns standard plan for white is pushing
these pawns
and it really and this is why the dragon
has such a sharp reputation
the evaluation really hangs on a thread
whoever slows down whoever falls behind
in these attacks
can easily end up like marshall did in
the last game they just get run over
they get run over by the pawn storm so
black goes b5
and b4
so now fischer goes knight d5
and the question here is after bishop d5
bishop d5
this is a big moment for black
in this position black can take on d5
after what white takes back on g7
and here this this middle game is good
for white
but black can go knight c3 check this is
a nice in-between move
and after bishop takes c3 even though
white wins a pawn here
even though white wins a pawn this end
game is okay for black this
in game is playable this is actually one
of the reasons that
castling is more popular now than bishop
c4
because thanks to these minor piece
exchanges black ends up all right
concretely
but as someone kind of touched on
and this is black is not playing for a
draw but a win
so larson wanted to attack two he didn't
want a position like this he didn't want
an end game like this
so instead of taking the bishop and
simplifying to an endgame
he plays rook c8
and fisher mentioned he was stunned by
this move you see again he wants to keep
the pieces on the board
but okay fischer wastes no time in
rescuing this bishop brings it back to
b3
and we're going to see just what a
powerful piece this bishop is
as it turns out empirically black just
can't allow white to keep this piece
because it serves it's a very it serves
multiple purposes
so black goes rook c7 you can kind of
see right it's already
stopping a couple of black's most
natural attacks
and fisher begins his own h4
and as he mentions fisher mentions in my
60 memorable games
i'd want dozens of skin skittles games
in analogous positions
and i had it down to a science pry open
the h file
sac sack mate
and this quote and a few games like this
did a lot to tarnish the dragon's
reputation
so larson goes queen b5 right c2 is well
defended
so he's looking at a5 a4 as a way to get
play
and fischer continues h5
so you can see the attack beginning
larson's still in a much better
situation practically speaking his
attack is much further along than
marshall was in the
other game but it's not enough he's
still behind
and you're going to see the consequences
black takes on h5 black sometimes does
this but it's usually extremely
dangerous including in this position
after bishop takes king takes
white goes g4 and we're seeing black
hasn't won a pawn black's just done
quite a favor opening this h file
knight f6 white checks and g5
this is a pretty classic dragon pattern
a lot of white winds look very similar
to this
after knight h5 the simplest way
white actually just crashes through sack
on h5
sack on h5 is one of the most classic
things to do in the dragon for white
and after g takes white can play g6 and
now we see the power of this bishop
pinning the f pawn and making this
breakthrough just end the game on the
spot
if black takes on g6 white can take
check and it's mate once the other rook
comes in
so all in all the general conclusion
from this line
is that it's absolutely foolhardy for
black to basically
give white any assistance in opening
these lines
and larson correctly moves the other
rook to c8 instead
not only does this go along with his
plan to put pressure on the queen side
right after a5 a4 c2 can be a very
problematic square
but it also gives this queen the
important f8 square to escape
so h takes h takes right now we're
seeing that
because black hasn't taken on h5 black
still has this bishop which controls the
h6 square
so white's attack is slower here and
black's attack is faster
so larson's at least putting up a good
fight so fischer goes g4
a5 and g5
right to induce right to induce knight
h5 anyway
i mean so you can see just how good this
is for white given that fischer is
spending all this time
just to get black to play it right if
the knight moves away
then white has white just eventually
moves the queen to the h file
and crashes through that way so larson
goes knight h5 walking this file
and as you might guess at this point
fischer goes rook takes h5
now here as it turns out
concretely the best defense for black
it's actually not to take the rook it's
to take this bishop
the bishop's a great defender of h8 it
covers a lot of the checkmates
that's part of why white's so eager to
trade it off in the dragon
white does trade it off and after takes
g6
this position is extremely dangerous for
black now if i saw it in the game i
would probably be convinced that black
was
just busted but as it turns out there's
what i'm almost going to call an engine
style
move black plays rook c4
this really highlights the power of this
bishop black would gladly give up in
exchange
just to cut it out of the attack
so after white takes problem is this
time
white just lacks the material and black
skin can run
again still a very not a pretty position
a few people would willingly take black
here
but at least this way white's attacking
forces are kept under better control
what's wrong with queen h2 instead up
queen takes d4 so if white plays queen
h2 instead of queen takes d4
the problem is when black still has this
bishop
it's harder to break through i mean even
if black goes bishop g7 it's hard for
white to actually find a mate here when
this bishop is here
right if this bishop were off the board
rook had entered the game but here it's
less clear
and rook here back and look at taking of
course here there is also
actually this one taking the rook would
probably be foolhardy but generally
speaking
this bishop is a very powerful defensive
piece
and that's why white's so eager to look
for this trade
instead though larson captures the rook
thinking rook rook h7 then rook takes g7
so let me find it
queen h4 it's a decent idea
it's this is a pretty typical attacking
idea
here i think though black can bring
enough defensive forces quickly enough
the queen can potentially replace the
bishop
and black does have some threats of
their own
it's certainly an idea worth looking at
though
so instead though instead of taking the
bishop as he should larson takes the
rook
and now we see the power of this bishop
fischer simply plays g6
and even though he's down in exchange
it's still the most powerful piece on
the board
if you remember the previous line where
bishop takes d4 was good
you might it might occurred to play rook
c4 here
and rook c4 this is a good try from
black the difference though
the difference here is that white takes
on f7 takes on g7
and we actually have the same position
with one difference
this king is on g7 instead of f7
and because of that the white rook joins
in with check
and this one extra tempo means the
attack is crushing
after king a7 white has queen h6
which threatens mate with queen g6 queen
g8
and after say king e8 queen e6
black's just getting run over right if
black keeps trying to run rook g8 wins
everything
queen here black will get mated soon
so we see that if black goes for the
same idea with rook c4 there's a fatal
loss
of tempo
larson instead to keep this bishop
larson makes a very committal move e5
right this stops the trade but on the
flip side
it exposes black's king
and right it means that this bishop is
not going to be an active participant
for a very long time
and actually the third problem it makes
d6 weak because the pawn is no longer on
e7
yeah it's it is pretty incredible just
how quickly black's position can fall
apart
once this initial line of defense on h7
or on the
on the h file breaks down
and fischer just goes bishop e3
right doesn't look too sharp but simply
speaking this king
is in a very unsteady situation white's
looking at breaking through with queen
d6
and white's also looking at simply
playing bishop h6
when white's pieces are just going to
invade there are too many lines into the
black position
and you're seeing again black's attack
black's attack is one move away from
being serious actually
a4 targeting the bishop and the c2
square black's attack is very close to
being serious unlike marshalls
but it's still just too slow it's a move
or two too slow and that's all
and that's all it takes
arson plays d5 trying to cut off support
for this pawn
fischer simply plays e takes
and this would be the moment if there
were one this would be the moment for a4
alright the bishop's trap but as it
turns out white simply plays d6
takes and takes c7
and now white's established a material
advantage if black takes on a2
just play king a1 and black's king is
still
not in a good situation not long for the
world
yeah so this would be the moment to play
a4 as you can see it's close
if black got one more move it would have
worked but it's not close enough
so larson just takes on f7 trying to
contain this attack
trying to at least say i have the extra
exchange if i can
i can even give that back right if i
could give a rook back for this bishop
maybe i could defend that position so
you know i've got something going for me
but still i mean this is a monster piece
again
offensively and defensively you're
probably seeing just how bitterly
larson regrets not trading it
and it's going to win the game so rook
f6
and bishop g5 and the white pieces
simply come storming in
right there i mean there simply isn't a
good move if rook g6
i can simply go bishop e7
and d7 not the only win but
the fastest yeah white's d2 queen and b3
bishop defend the queen side
while black's rooks are horrible for
kingside defense that is true these have
been some
very good multipurpose pieces for white
but the key again really is that i mean
we i've talked a bit if the key really
is that larson fell behind
right if black could play this move with
the rooks on the c file
life would be pretty good life could
even be great for him it does not take
much
for white's position instead of blacks
to be busted in the dragon
but when you're behind on the attack it
just doesn't work
so rook f6 bishop g5 and now white's
pieces come swarming in
right black goes back back with queen b7
to bring the queen back on the defense
white grabs his material back
and plays d7 i mean this cuts the queen
off
even if it weren't for the attack right
this is an extra pawn on d7
even if it weren't for the attack this
would be a completely winning material
advantage
and after rook d8 here's a little puzzle
for you guys
what is the fastest checkmate for white
here
white to play and mate in three
fisher fisher played a move that's
completely winning so i can't really
criticize it but
he makes a little joke about this in my
60 memorable games
that there was actually a faster win
right queen h6 check is the fastest
the point being if bishop g7 queen c6 is
a nice checkmate
and if e7 queen h7 and the queen makes
its way to f7
checkmate
fischer instead played queen d6
don't don't get me wrong this is
completely winning certainly no no one
in their right mind would call it a
mistake
and it was good enough that after queen
d6 larson actually resigned the game
because after king g7 white just plays
rook h1
king h7 and queen f6 and while white
hasn't made it yet
hasn't made it as quickly as queen h6
it's not difficult to tell that black's
king is not long for the world
and of course you know blacks down a
piece as long as white notices there's a
back rank mate threat here
see probably the fastest mate is check
check and made on g7 after this
yeah so a very nice game by fischer in
this position larson saw what was coming
white's attack crashed through and
larson resigned
so all in all those two games are very
good examples of powerful king side
attacks
in the first one in alakin's game we saw
marshall's attack never really got
started
and that's because alakan set up a
middle game where
or his pawns were so well suited to
attack black
we saw that
in this position
we see how much powerful white's attack
is when white already has proper control
for the pawns
and black's pieces are giving them free
tempi as they advance
so part of it right part of it's not
just executing the attack but like
alkine did here reaching a position
where the attack is good right here
white's
we've got opposite side castling attacks
but it's like white got three or four
free moves in the meantime
it's a very nice strategy by alakine and
others we saw an excellently
orchestrated attack
in the fischer game things were much
closer we had a typical dragon line
we had a typical dragon line in which
larson played the logical dragon moves
but he made made one big mistake
which was not trading off this bishop
which like as we saw in the game is a
monster
dual purpose piece that created serious
threats against black's king and
completely killed black's offensive idea
and even with just basically i would say
this one major mistake
along with some other defensive
possibilities in a bad position
was enough that larson just got crushed
so very
very interesting middle game positions
and two very well executed attacks by
two of the best players ever
yeah so i hope you guys enjoyed those
games thank you all for watching
does anyone anyone have any questions
larson also made the mistake of playing
the dragon this is true like i said as a
result
as a result of this game and some other
ones with
similar fates the rep the opening's
reputation took a significant hit
of course i will say it too though it
doesn't take much it doesn't have to
mess up much if white makes an analogous
mistake to larson's in this game
you know a similar mistake then white
can easily
just get run over right if for example
in
in and say a position like this if black
can pull off a4 before white's attack
crashes through
then the same thing can happen to white
if i can easily end up dead lost
manny i will be on shortly for my second
lecture which is games of the week
some actually some very nice attacking
wins by nepo
what do i think with black's lines with
h5 in response to h4
i mean it's complicated all in all
i mean those lines are extremely sharp
right black's in a lot of danger it's
very concrete
you really just have to know in those
kinds of lines exactly what you're doing
because white's committing material
and of course black's opening up lines
for the attack
so really whoever it's it's the kind of
position like this game
where any kind of error by either side
has disastrous consequences
um for the second lecture i will still
be here nathan
and opposite side castling is central
control important
yes central control is extremely
important
because pieces in the center
these pieces in the center have are very
good dual purpose pieces
you know especially knights which are
kind of slow and night in the center of
the board can still affect both wings
central control enables your pieces to
do a lot to influence a lot of the poor
support at once
and actually if we take a position like
this so let's go to say this position
it's not just that white has a kingside
attack with these spawns here
white is badly cramping black's pieces
right you can see white's pieces kind of
have a free hand to go to the kingside
everything apart from this knight which
is well controlled by the bishop
has a free hand to play on the king side
on the same time black is badly
restricted in space thanks to these
pawns controlling the central square
um is sacrificing the rook for the
knight on c3 normal in these types of
positions
so yes in the dragon it wasn't so
relevant this game let me see
it wasn't so relevant this game because
by the time black played would see it
the knight was already gone
but yes in the dragon playing rook takes
c3 as black to induce b
takes is very thematic it's in all sorts
of wines
sometimes even for the end game it can
make a very strong attack but even in
the end game it can be good compensation
especially with this bishop
do i have a twitch stream yes i do it's
actually my
it's gm zerk so gm and then my last name
if you'd like to take a look
but those are two great games from two
of my favorite players
i hope you guys enjoyed them any other
questions
all right well then i will see you in a
little bit for
games of the week thanks for the
complimenting on
and i hope you can check out that other
lecture bye everyone